[Music]
i am brayden hamilton and i am the
founder of orca asphalt maintenance
one of our primary services is asphalt
sealcoating i'm going to walk you
through how we clean repair and seal
an asphalt driveway
so typically when we show up on a
project we assess the driveway and we
see cracks
now cracks are inevitable over time
asphalt moves and typically what we see
is cracks down the seams of the asphalt
which could be in the center of the
driveway or where the driveway meets the
road so before we start our sealcoating
project there is a lot of dirt and
debris grime oils that need to be
cleaned off the reason for this is we
want our sealer to properly adhere to
the asphalt
after the driveway is cleaned we then
use an oil spot primer on any spots
where oil has been leaked from out of
cars or motorcycles this oil spot primer
is poured on the spot and then applied
with a broom to work it in this ensures
that the oil doesn't penetrate through
and that our sealer is able to stick on
that surface
crack sealing is an essential part of
the process as it prevents water from
penetrating into the asphalt that water
can wash away the base which will
eventually lead to asphalt failure the
asphalt on top can cave in and potholes
can form and much worse issues can arise
we begin the repair by ensuring that
crack is perfectly clean and then we use
our push behind melters which melt a
rubber compound it comes out of the
machine through a spout and into the
shoe which is then walked along the
crack filling the void
this rubber compound is formulated to
expand and contract with the thermal
expansion of the asphalt
typically one pass is needed but if that
crack is large we need to go over top of
that crack several times to ensure it's
properly sealed
in the winter months the asphalt will
contract leaving a larger void in that
asphalt and in the summer it expands
leaving the cracks smaller we want a
compound that can get in there and
expand and contract with that crack
ensuring that it doesn't open up and
further moisture can penetrate
the push behind melter is heated to 350
degrees celsius which is the perfect
temperature for the rubber to come out
of the machine and fill the crack at a
perfect consistency
now that we're done repairing the cracks
we're going to move on to seal coating
the driveway
seal coating protects from salt uv rays
water penetration and many other
contaminants
we use a professional-grade asphalt
emulsion sealer that has compounds that
ensure that it's durable and non-slip
so in a residential setting we use
specialized seal coating brooms so the
product is applied in lines and then we
come behind with brooms sweeping it back
and forth working that sealer into the
asphalt pores
seal coating a driveway is a little bit
like a dance so we've got typically two
people on a project and we are working
it back and forth pulling it down on the
edges working our edges and then working
the middle all at the same time so that
it cures in beautifully
so our sealer is housed in a tank we
have a pump that pumps it out of the
tank through a hose and out of a wand
through this wand comes the sealer and
it is applied in lines and then we come
behind with brooms and we work that
sealer back and forth back and forth
working it into the pores and leaving a
perfect finish
so when the sealer is applied it has a
brown color and it cures to a jet black
we chalk line a perfect line at the end
of the driveways and then we mask it off
so that when we pull the sealer onto the
masking paper and pull it up at the end
customers are left with a perfect line
it will typically take between three and
four hours to walk on the driveway but
we always recommend 24 to 48 hours prior
to driving
we recommend that driveways are seal
coated every three to four years we
recommend getting this process done in
the summer months as the temperatures
allow it to cure properly and fast